this is a production of Cornell
University Thank You Carl okay yeah I'll
be talking a bit about my research of
malting barley today okay so in 2012
there were 92 craft breweries in New
York for breweries in general New York
now in 2018 we have over 400 breweries
in New York and that timeframe breweries
across United States boom but the growth
and breweries is particularly striking
in New York State much of this could be
attributed to the farm brewery bill this
is a state bill that it was passed in
2012 that provides economic incentives
for locally produced ingredients
specifically at the current quota farm
breweries must use at least 20% locally
grown hops and 20% locally grown malts
these incentives that quota increases
the 60 percent in 2019 so this is a
couple weeks here and increases finally
to 9% in 2024 currently we're producing
an up malting barley in New York to meet
these quotas even if the 60% increase in
2019 however Cornell Cooperative
Extension has set an ambitious goal of
30,000 acres by 2023 to account for the
demand at the 90 percent quota so we're
to meet that meet that goal we must
increase malting barley acreage in New
York however high quality multi bar
leaves not an easy thing to produce in
New York this is largely due to the wet
humid climate in New York that we
frequently have during our summers
there's a long list of problems that can
happen I'm gonna talk about two today
specifically the first is pre-harvest
freighting which is a premature loss of
dormancy in the field before the grain
is harvested which can reduce which
results in early germination when a
moisture event occurs such as a heavy
dew or prolonged rain the second that
I'll talk about is foliar disease
specifically Lee for us and smog watch
these are both diseases they can cause a
loss in stock logic and also negatively
in
impact grain quality so to meet these
challenges the Cornell small grains
breeding program initiated a project
that we're calling born bred and brewed
and our goals are to support farm
brewing by quickly meeting the needs of
local monsters and brewers who are
operating under the farm brewery bill
we're hoping to breed high dormancy to
avoid fear of sprouting disease
resistant varieties that have high multi
quality across the variety of New York
environments wealth and quality also
needs to be stable because monsters and
brewers need a consistent supply of malt
to make consistent here year after year
so to do this we're establishing a two
row spring barley breeding program at
cornell monsters and brewers want a New
York barley variety yesterday act
quickly naturally assumed and I'm in
Sorrells lab and then my Cornell our
perch is going to be genomic selection
but we wanted to make this we want to
hit a homerun on the first try because
with this strict time limit set by the
farm brewery bill we don't have a lot of
time to waste in breeding so our
approach is to use a nested Association
mapping style designs for our genomic
prediction training population those not
familiar with the nested Association
mapping panel or an am basically a
collection of have said families
connected by a common parent and the
idea here is to use the beneficial
statistical properties of Anam to
increase our prediction accuracy high
relatedness large population size more
efficient genotyping use the population
structure
[Music]
ideally increasing a variance multiple
families instead of just one or two and
then also high power for genome-wide
association studies since we're doing
genomic prediction we're not interested
in a genetic architecture per se of
these traits but we're interested in
adding and he fixed that any of pipe
effects markers low side has fixed
effects in our prediction models even if
none of these work it's the use of
breeding population to start a breeding
program
so our approach was to use variety AAC
synergy is our common parent this is
performed fairly well for us in New York
State it has high yield time wealth
quality and high disease resistance but
does not have a good harvest riding
resistance we use seven other parents
energy and we ended up with a population
of about 1,300 lines so a little under
200 lines per family in 2017 so last
field season to locate two hetero
locations of f3 derived at four lines
were grown and you know type for the
traits listed there to train the
prediction model and this year a subset
of 100 lines from that training
population were thrown into regional
yield trials and I'll come back to that
so this principal component analysis
here shows and gives a nice indication
of population structure here so because
got a little washed out with the green
and orange cross is made from North
American germ plasm North American
barley germ plasm is not very diverse
it's been heavily selected for multi
quality over the past years so it's all
pretty closely related right there at
the top you can stairs this little
yellow cluster it's actually a back
cross we didn't realize the New Deal is
one of the parents but it is so we have
that and then the blue dots are in the
middle that's a European by Canadian
cross and the European multi Varley germ
plasm is kept very separate so a lot
more diversity there okay so our
genotyping approach in this population
was to genotype the progeny at a higher
flex than the parents so with this many
wines and needed for libraries so the
parents are present in each of those
library each of those four libraries for
the progeny only present wants so the
parents got sequence at four times
greater depth progeny we are able to
line these sequences to the recently
updated by in our first genome which is
pretty good so we're confident in our
physical positions of these markers
because all the parents are inbred lines
and released varieties I was pretty
stringent with the parental filters so
removed any heterozygote
heterozygous sites any missing sites and
only kept I was very confident for those
geo type calls and then within family I
included markers for those parents and
any other missing data were imputed with
expectation-maximization in our blood
and are the usual heterozygosity in
family and then a final filter to remove
with each other so that gives me about
six thousand okay so I'm working here
with single trait G blood models that's
it and as our you can tested with the
five so there's a lot going on here but
these gray boxes correspond to friction
activities with the entire set and each
of the colored boxes refers the
individual families here so there's a
couple trans that jump out here the
first is that when you look at the gray
boxes these prediction actresses for the
whole set they tend to be as high or
higher than prediction accuracy is
within each family we're hoping to see
prediction accuracy is within each
family vary widely depending on a cheat
rate varies a lot
specifically notice this yellow box here
in the middle family and has
consistently low prediction accuracy for
games great and is consistently lower
than the majority of the other families
the standard deviations for the
prediction accuracies are quite a bit
higher for pre-harvest sprouting and
spot watch is likely due to incomplete
no typing for those traits pre ever
sprouting is a very labor-intensive and
time-sensitive phenotype so we weren't
able to phenotype at large the
population and then spot watch the data
was incomplete due to premature
senescence because a rapid disease
progression
jiwa models were fit in our book with a
single principle component added to
account for population structure the
hits that we see for leaf rust and force
pop watch lie within regions that have
been previously not for these two traits
we're fairly confident these are real
this very large effects locus here for
pre-harvest writing is in the region
that a recency gene wiesen and that
German so also confident about that and
this height locus is close to Earth
energy using here Ian malting barley
germ plasm and that alleles on the
present in the European cross
so the marker data that's useful so
again we're not interested in understand
these traits we want to see if it
increases prediction accuracy but
fortunately it seems that only adding
that very large increases prediction
accuracy every when we take a little bit
closer look at trait heritability and
percentages Matic variance explained by
these low-side the pictures a little
more clear so Rex Bernardo was looking
at the same problem and a simulation
study in 2010 and his results somewhat
mirror mine so for traits that have low
heritability and have say gee Wasat that
doesn't explain that much of the genetic
variance to something like height or
spot watch low percentage of genetic
creation' explain adding a picture that
doesn't really change accuracy which is
what we see for height and spot watch
however for a trait like pre-harvest
sprouting that has very high
heritability and has a lot of that
genetic variance not surprisingly that
will increase your prediction accuracy
which is what we see leave for us is a
bit puzzling though because we have high
heritability and the percentage of
genetic variance explained is not low
but it's not really increasing the
accuracy so that's a little mysterious
still when we use the 2017 training
population data though to predict
unobserved trial trials adding fixative
x as a more significant impact so n here
is a number of 2008 that tres4 measured
n so when we add fixed effects through
these traits you can see prediction
accuracy increases quite a bit
especially for Korea responding
illustrates there's something like
pretty reverse crowding this is
particularly promising
pre-harvest routing like I said is a
very time intensive and labor-intensive
process to phenotype and we can only do
this locally but it's one of our most
important traits having good predictions
for I observe yield trials for this
trait would be of great value
another thing we'd like to do and we're
starting a genomic selection project
from scratch is to use a few markers as
possible to reduce costs so at a number
of different marker densities going from
full marker density all the way to one
per set I sample these entities and use
five fold cross validation to test sets
promising lis it looks like we can go
down to about 10% of the total marker
set and maintain prediction accuracy for
most rates
so that's markers this is partially do I
think because barley naturally has high
population structure helps you see more
prediction accuracy tails off likely due
to that when you're only sampling a
marker in LD with that main cause of
locus decreases accordingly so
prediction accuracy drops lastly we
would like to have a lot of work so I
did use a similar conservation strategy
and testing smaller training population
sets for most traits we can get down to
fifty seventy-five population set size
and still maintain accuracy every day we
see this major drop-off in pre have a
sprouting I think that that's so I'm
only harvesting when you drop that by
seventy five or fifty percent you have
many fewer individuals that you're using
there so with these results and our
regional yield trails in 2018 plus
healed trials next year we're confident
that in New York malting barley isn't
been reach we've identified high
yielding disease resistant and
pre-harvest writing resist behind but we
still don't know how they malts across
environments across years so this data
we're waiting on and that picture become
work for the next year
we're definitely speeding this process
along and we're hoping to identify
riot II candidate and all 2019 and get
that in Foundation seed in 2020 hopeful
farmer Luke's in the next year to the
other part of my dissertation research
is using selections from the straining
population to initiate a genomic
selection experiment currently we did
two rounds of that by validation will be
this summer in the fields soon for that
I would like to thank my committee
members actually present members in
Sorrells lab and folks in the Burj Dubai
on slab as well as funding partners and
if that would be happy to take any
questions
[Applause]
mark had grown yield trials for two or
three years before I got here and at the
time those were our best performers in
the day she had going back I would not
choose some of those parents
particularly retail the one that was the
back cross but uh yeah sorry so Margaret
asked why did we choose the parents that
we did we went on what existing data we
had three years of yield trials but if I
were to do this again I would choose
some different parents yeah I'm just
curious like what you could do because I
feel like all the prediction actor sees
like what you really wanted was the pre
sprouted we pre are sprouting yeah but
like that was the hardest thing to
predict at least like with lower markers
and things like that so yeah what could
you do - this is the identical question
if you were to do the experiment again
is there something you could do
differently to like make sure your
predictions of that are better yeah so I
think the biggest thing since I've been
more completely and I think that that
sorry-looking in the question so the
question was forever surrounding is our
most important trait but had the most
severe drop in prediction accuracy when
we did subsets
I think the keator is more like I said
we only phenotype about 400 to 450 of
those 1,300 lines because you have to
sample them at physiological maturity
which has a very short window so either
we hired three times as many undergrads
which could work or we have a smaller
size or work 16-hour days either one of
those but I'm I was pretty happy with
the prediction accuracy who did
differently harvest writing we knew very
little about the genetic control of this
trait and our population and how it
worked in New York we haven't looked
fair idea of N and wheat but these
results I think are useful early
okay yeah yes was that from a good was
it from the other ones overall yeah so
the question was there's this kind of
extra blind take which is a European
variety from kws so bread for
continental European climates like
France and Germany which in our
experience those lines and to perform a
little bit better New York there's a lot
of barley breeding in the UK but those
lines are adapted to a maritime climate
what school in the UK and you can get
pretty hot summers the lines thread for
Germany in France the better if you
don't typically it looks fairly similar
it is a little bit shorter it's
susceptible to several diseases here but
it has a good mounting quality these are
all to row lines so to malting barley
all kind of sort of looks the same
unless you spend hours in the FIFO so
yeah it looks similar but as a lot more
teenagers alright thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu